foreign
at a glance this looks like any other
night out
people are mingling
the DJ is bumping
the bartender is mixing
but there's one key thing missing
alcohol
there's not a drop of it here
we like to create an atmosphere where
everybody is sober and so you're kind of
forced to sit down and actually get to
know somebody without this veil of
alcohol Elizabeth gascoigne is the host
of this booze free bar night
she came up with the idea a year ago
after deciding to go sober like many
people she found herself drinking too
much during the pandemic leaving her
with something she calls anxiety
anxiety in my experience is the feeling
that you get the next day after drinking
even if you're only drinking a glass or
two of wine just this residual anxiety
of what did I say the night before what
did I do did I embarrass myself it's a
question her generation is posing a
recent study found they drink 20 percent
less than Millennials who in turn are
drinking less than gen xers and Baby
Boomers and it's not necessarily because
they have addiction issues they're just
curious
sober curious
gen Z I think is a generation that is
really learning about mental health
practices a very Pro therapy generation
and I think they're realizing that like
maybe the consequences of alcohol are
not actually worth the mental health
effects
here's the thing she still wanted to go
out and party but finding a fun booze
free option was a struggle even in New
York where she lives okay that's good so
she decided to create her own sober
soirees events she calls absence of
proof
when I stopped drinking I still wanted
the same nightlife experience of going
out to a bar meeting new friends maybe
dancing you know all of these fun things
that go along with nightlife that I
couldn't find at a coffee shop or any of
these other places and so I decided to
start throwing a non-alcoholic party and
see who would show up she was shocked by
the response
[Music]
the first party was crazy we ended up
having over 200 people at the launch
party which was way too many that I I
wasn't prepared for that but um it was
great
so great that she quit her Tech job and
now does this full time she hosts two or
three events a month in New York she
recently launched in Los Angeles
and tonight is her first party in her
hometown of Seattle
sober curiosity is more than just
swapping Spirits for soft drinks at this
party there's non-alcoholic wine and
beer but the zero proof cocktails are
the real draw the majority of our
cocktails do mimic the flavors of
alcoholic Cocktails so they all have
non-alcoholic gin non-alcoholic tequila
or non-alcoholic whiskey this is a new
take on an old-fashioned it's not
exactly the same but it's got like the
same kind of profile to it
but I gotta tell you it goes down way
easier than the hard stuff
you might say absence of proof is actual
proof of the evolution of drinking
culture
[Music]
once pervasive often glamorized so let's
drink to it but now seen more and more
like smoking
here in Canada the sober curiosity
movement is definitely brewing beer and
wine sales are at an all-time low except
when it comes to non-alcoholic products
non-alc beer alone is expected to grow
by more than eight percent each year
and at the drive canteen in Vancouver
they can attest to that this pale ale
like you could pour it blind and people
wouldn't know that it's a de-alkalized
product it's so good
owner Doug Steven has carefully curated
his convenience store with a focus on
fun
candy and snacks jerseys and sneakers
and their top seller beer Wine and
Spirits without the booze
as long as it's delicious that's the
biggest thing for us we really saw the
pickup occur in December of 2022 and we
thought that this must be New Year's and
Christmas parties and people stocking up
and then January came and it was dry
January and we just keep seeing more and
more people coming through who um want
to kind of shift how they view alcohol
it's clear there is a thirst for
something different
and Fiona heifer wants to quench that
thirst this should be more on the dry of
the spectrum she's the CEO of sansorium
a BC based Online Marketplace for
alcohol-free beverages
tonight she's giving people a taste of
what's out there the big takeaway I hope
people get from tonight is really an
expanded definition about sobriety you
could have a mindful relationship to
alcohol that lets you have a drink once
in a while or you realize that you don't
like it at all and you decide to leave
it without having this Rock Bottom story
and this sober curious are eager to
sample
I think there's something about getting
something that tastes like an adult
beverage that's what I loved about it
the growing demand for a zero proof
adult beverages has drawn some to switch
sides shall we say
[Music]
Tyler Harleton used to run a successful
Winery in BC's Okanagan Valley until he
stopped drinking and shut it down in
2019. that was my last vintage and that
was sort of the end of a chapter of
making alcoholic wine
he didn't miss the buzz but he did miss
the taste so Tyler returned to doing
what he does best making premium wine
but this time without the alcohol
turns out that there are a lot of people
like me or my partner that really want
to enjoy premium but to enjoy premium
without the without the burden of the
alcohol
[Music]
partnered with Chris paleokini an old
friend from his Winery days who grew up
among these Orchards
their goal to stay true to the grape
without making grape juice and not using
vinegar as a base as many non-elk wines
do we like to use actual grapes
themselves we wanted to use the
fermentation process because it's the
only way to unlock some of those flavors
the challenge is removing the alcohol
without losing the Integrity of the wine
wine is quite complex there's hundreds
of different chemical compounds we're
just removing one which is ethanol or
alcohol
and when we remove that it kind of
changes how you perceive the flavor how
you perceive the aroma how you perceive
melt feel
it took a year of experimentation and
hundreds of tries but finally they had
it
Canada's only non-alcoholic wine made
from BC grapes
they call it once what has the progress
been like since you started it's been
faster than exponential growth in terms
of production and we find we still can't
keep up with demand at this point
were you surprised by that I shocked I
had no idea like I thought it was just
going to be this kind of curious side
project that we talked about but the
demand and the the reaction from
consumers has been unbelievable we never
I would never have guessed this
since I know what wine tastes like I
wanted to see for myself how it compared
have a Sniff and see what you smell
and and you you tell us if you get
anything is it differently
because this is Pinot Noir yeah
[Music]
very very light it's like a very light
Pinot Noir and it's not sweet which is
great yeah because I kind of it's got
like a juiciness to it but it makes me
think it wouldn't would be sweet but
it's
definitely dry yeah I like it yeah I'm
kind of mind blown right now yeah for us
it's really nice when someone has that
aha moment where they could imagine this
being wine of course it's not just about
the taste customers tell Chris and Tyler
that their wines help them feel included
in Social settings
they can pop a cork pour a glass and
still feel like they're in the mix
proof that life without liquor can be
just as fun
and everyone even the sober curious
can find a seat at the table
[Music]